and then I found out like you know some
of my closest and best friends are just
straight-up libertarian there we have
like a kind of a coming out towards I
like do so do I vote libertarian oh I do
too hey you know that sort of thing
hey I'm holding jerk with reason TV
today we're talking with Heather Anne
Campbell she's a comedy writer here in
Los Angeles she's written for a Saturday
Night Live for Cartoon Network's
incredible crew she's performed with
what is a whose line is it anyway
with improv a ganzel drew carey's in
propaganda Heather thanks for joining us
thank you you're involved in a new
program on the Fox network called ADHD
can you just explain for us what is ADHD
where can we see it all right coming in
July Fox has a block of programming it's
all animated ADHD stands for animation
domination and high definition there are
a slate of short format shows that will
be going up on their late-night Saturday
night block some of them have already
been announced like let's see axe cop
which is based on a webcomic of the same
name that then became a full-length
comic and how long are these shows these
are these shows are 15 minutes long I
mean with commercials yeah and then I
also write all of well most of all of
these shorts for online distribution all
the original shorts like Charlie Brown
Christmas reunion or scientifically
accurate spider-man very very funny I've
seen a lot of it myself
I'm a fan of the animation as well it is
an amazing team that is all in-house
like we don't ship out the animation to
anywhere it's all done in the building
okay it's yeah it reminds me of like
cartoons and I watch them I was a kid
yeah yeah except well hopefully not as
vulgar as the things that you watch
doesn't kid yes it's true yes there's a
lot of dicks I mean a lot of dicks in a
lot of that stuff yeah we were like we
were actually debating like well should
we play it in the back there's a lot of
turtle day yeah there's a lot of turtle
thing turtles have giant penises so it's
not starting on the internet but it's
definitely being promoted on the
Internet's getting a lot of lot of views
from people that just like share it
around what do you think is like the
philosophy of that my
bosses Nick Wyden Feld handbag daddy
they have a very progressive engagement
with the internet community a lot of
Adult Swim yeah you know Millennials are
are very active online so they embrace
where fan where fandom is created like
the epicenter of a fandom is sort of
online engagement well like what about
just generally like internet and comedy
how has it changed over the last like
maybe decade or so
the internet has sort of given everybody
the ability to make comedy like it used
to be that unless you had a fifteen
thousand dollar VHS camera and a private
theater that it was impossible to shoot
something and and bring it to people and
I feel like the Internet's been a great
equalizer it shows you at the same time
how overvalued creation of comedy is and
then how undervalued good comedy is over
the past like thirty years or so comedy
has become not just something for Laughs
it's become something where it
disseminates the news it's we can
confront these serious topics with
comedy where do you see it going it's so
funny I read this uh this MTV study just
yesterday this study said that more kids
want to be comedians than they want to
be rock stars now and more kids get
their news from comedy than from
anywhere else Daily Show Colbert oh yeah
yeah yeah I think that's terrifying but
if you have to couch information in a
funny presentation that's great I would
rather that people learn about the world
some way then not learn about it at all
but when you do the news as comedy your
point of view has to be in the sentence
like you have to make obvious what it is
that you're trying to say about what
you're reporting on and it's it's a
service to what Jon Stewart like
specifically finds interesting himself
or you know Stephen Colbert or John
Oliver or whatever yeah like it's the
things that they are interested in
engaging it almost is like the
traditional news anchor role you know
the way that anchors used to drive the
news as opposed to be a service to
whatever the front end of their
conglomerate I don't know yeah okay you
spend a lot of time doing improv
you've done drew carey's improvin Kansa
done whose line is it anyway you're sort
of a cog in the indie improv community
here and here in Los Angeles what's the
what's the thrill of improv yeah I mean
on a like I hope this doesn't sound
pathetic but it's so nice to be able to
divorce myself from whatever my
responsibilities are and become people
who are always less responsible than
myself like when I'm on stage I don't
have to worry about my deadlines or you
know the oil leak in my car I just have
to like take care of the scene and play
and listen and engage my partner and all
of the things that are in my agenda are
somewhere off stage so on a personal
private level it's just that it's fun to
get to be an elf or it's fun to be you
know in a burning house or whatever and
not have any of it be real astronaut you
can be a vampire
exactly it's fantastic yeah um so I mean
like as long as that doesn't sound crazy
that'll be the answer I stick to your a
reason reader you're interested in like
many libertarian ideas civil liberties
being one of them let see reaction to
this whole National Security Agency
surveillance of phones of Americans ah
it doesn't surprise me um there was I
read a cypherpunks by Julian Assange and
he talks about this pre-existing like
wiretapping surveillance state before
any of this information was officially
leaked by Edward Snowden
you know the truth is I think it's it's
a liability for the government because
it's inevitable that something's going
to slip through their fingers and
they're just going to be more
accountable for not having done anything
about it when all of the emails are on a
on a server somewhere that the
government has does that make sense like
to explain that well unless you have
some unfathomably complicated algorithm
that can go through huge volumes of
information and and try and deduce
likelihoods then it's just storage you
know and unless there's this you know a
person connecting those dots it's just
something that is that's being
it's like if you were to record on VHS
every single CCTV camera in the United
States it's just a tape you know unless
there's somebody going through all that
tape so I think in the future it's going
to be something they wish they hadn't
have done because people be like well
you had all this access why didn't you
do something and they'll be like well we
don't know what to do with all the
information we're just keeping it it's a
nightmare
I mean like I know what I would love to
be clear it's a nightmare
I'm gonna be a Google glass Explorer and
when the story broke I was like oh man
do I not oh do I not ever put the
goggles on my head like I was so excited
to get my own futuristic heads-up
display and I'm like it's just gonna be
broadcasting just gonna see what eyes
yeah I'm just gonna go see what I see
gonna see the weird YouTube videos you
want yeah yeah I mean it's a if I'm not
already flagged for oh yeah that's
whatever you know how do your political
interests how do they affect sketch
writing comedy writing just in general
there are times where like with the ROE
bomb apiece where it's pretty clear what
my point of view politically is that
these guys are kind of the same talking
points and they're pursuing the same
agenda yeah uh that it's obvious I
didn't go into that piece being like I'm
gonna write a libertarian sketch it was
more like what would be the funniest
thing that would happen is they kind of
talked about the same things at the
debate last night so why don't we just
literally make them the same person I
don't know how people chose between the
two of them I guess it was just all like
buzzwords like if Romney head and said
47% he might have won yeah what does
that mean so I don't go into uh into
pieces thinking how can I make a
libertarian sketch I never I never think
that it's always what's funny
yeah it's what's funniest and I think
the best way to to serve libertarian or
political libertarianism is to just do
the best work and then when people find
out you're a libertarian they're like Oh
what does that mean and they look it up
for themselves like I'm not don't shove
it down people yeah I'm not trying to be
Neri for anything no but you do read
recent magazine yes I read every I read
Reason magazine I read it on my iPad
yeah a lot of my friends are you know
pro marijuana legalization and that
prohibition is a nightmare and that the
prison industrial complex is terrible
they won't describe themselves as
libertarian but when you lay out all of
their points of view for them it's like
well that's what the platform is and
then I found out like you know some of
my closest and best friends are just
straight-up libertarian there we had
like a kind of a coming out towards I
like do you so do you
I vote libertarian oh I do too hey you
know that sort of thing
and hopefully your Google glass and I'll
be able to watch it on there that'll be
a glass from a net I registered that
really of course I did oh my god I want
to make money so I'm gonna put the
videos up and yeah yeah yeah well I'll
see what I see yeah sketch comedy
through glass